l'image est lourde de sens bible à la
main donald trump a voulu répondre aux
tensions qui touche les états unis après
la mort de georges floyd annonçant
vouloir restaurer la grandeur de son
pays
le président américain a surtout été la
cible de critiques en cause la
dispersion brutale de manifestants
pacifiques devant la maison blanche pour
permettre cette séance photo une
démarche qui ne prend pas et qui
révoltent même l'évêque du diocèse et
piste au cal de washington les
présidents vient d'utiliser une bible
est l'une des églises de mon diocèse
sans autorisation comme décor pour un
message contraire aux enseignements de
jésus et à tous que nos églises
représente je ne peux pas croire ce que
mes yeux ont vu je suis scandalisé
l'utilisation de gaz lacrymogènes pour
évacuer les manifestants et ainsi briser
l'image du président enterré dans le
bunker de la maison blanche ne passe pas
auprès de l'opposition
au sénat les démocrates y voit même une
atteinte à la liberté d'expression et
prépare un projet de loi condamnant
l'attitude de donald trump envers les
manifestants cette résolution choisi
condamne le président pour ce qu'il a
fait je sais que l'écrasante majorité
des américains sera d'accord avec nous
le droit constitutionnel garantit aux
américains le droit de se réunir
pacifiquement d'exercer leur liberté
d'expression ainsi que le droit de
pétition
ce pacte est alors que la campagne
reprend pour le rival démocrate de
donald trump joe biden accuse le
président américain d'avoir transformé
les etats-unis ont un champ de bataille
nous devons être vigilants face à la
violence que le président en exercice
fait subir à notre économie et à notre
justice lorsque des manifestants
pacifiques sont dispersés avec des gaz
lacrymogènes et des grenades et claire
pour qu'un président puisse organiser
une séance de photos sur l'une des
églises les plus historiques du pays ou
du moins à washington dc
on peut nous pardonner de croire que le
président est plus intéressé par le
pouvoir que par le principe de subvenir
aux besoins des personnes dont il a la
charge
pour ne rien arranger donald trump s'est
opposé frontalement à la mobilisation
des manifestants
le président américain a demandé aux
villes et aux états concernés d'opter
pour des mesures fortes en cas de refus
il a menacé de faire appel aux
militaires
si une ville ou un état refuse de
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
défendre la vie et les biens de ses
habitants alors je déplorais l'armée des
états unis et je résoudrai rapidement le
problème à leur place je prend également
des mesures rapides et décisives pour
protéger notre grande capitale
washington dc ce qui s'est passé dans la
ville hier soir est une honte absolue
après le coronavirus donald trump doit
gérer une nouvelle crise qui prend la
forme d'une fracture à la fois racial et
social
une situation qui pourrait lui coûter
cher à cinq mois de la présidentielle
américaine